another day another lie from the public
health establishment a few days ago the
corporate media began reporting on the
first confirmed omnicron death in the
united states you may have noticed that
i did not report on that death because i
no longer believe anything the corporate
media tell me especially about
coronavirus
and it turns out i was right not to
believe them because as the journalist
dan cohen learned during a phone call
with the harris county public health
department the story is complete bs
we've just confirmed the first death in
the united states due to the omicron
variant in texas on monday texas
reported the country's first known
omicron death a man in his 50s who was
not vaccinated we can't confirm that the
patient died from covid but we can say
that
he was on a crown positive at the time
of his death so he so he died with covid
but you can't say that he died from
covet
correct this information comes from our
epidemiologists who are the ones who get
the reports they have to
do a very uh meticulous investigation
because you know they they do take this
very much at heart they're telling me
that they cannot say that
that kovid was the absolute cause of
death
if the public health officials could
plausibly blame this man's death on
kovid they would but they can't so
they're not doing that but the media
don't care about the truth so they're
running with it anyway
how long before people learn from those
sage words of george w bush fool me once
shame on you fool me twice hey well the
point is you're not going to fool me
again i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from giovanni
garcia who says
biden's stop it speech is like those
memes where it's just some instagram
girl who posts a selfie and captions it
hey racism stop it
yes that what that is
about the level of rhetoric and
statecraft that you're seeing from joe
biden and just as effective hey
virus stop it i'm going to shut you how
am i going to shut down the virus i'm
going to say stop it really angrily
just as angrily as i said stop it to
corn pop
and that'll do it that'll do it right i
don't think so i we need a little more
virility i think and on the subject of
virility if you're interested in such
things you might want to check out
roman
gentlemen
e.d
is really common it is it is no one
wants to talk about it but it is in fact
52
of guys aged 40 to 70
experience some form of erectile
dysfunction go to getroman.com
knowles canada wles right now to speak
to a u.s licensed healthcare
professional about e.d and get 15 bucks
off your first month of treatment roman
ready is confidence personified it is
the self-assurance that comes from
knowing you've prepared yourself for the
moment when intimacy arrives roman's
system is completely confidential and
totally discreet no big logos or labels
on packages with roman you can get a
free online evaluation and ongoing care
for ed all from the comfort and privacy
of your home a u.s licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships to you free with
two day shipping getting started is
simple just go to getroman.com
knowles know w las to complete an online
visit go to getroman.com
if you're prescribed get 15 bucks off
your first month of ed treatment make
sure you're ready to have confidence and
control this season roman ready go check
out roman today
the first omicron death in the united
states it's a lie
even at the time the more honest news
sources
were reporting that the the man who died
had
other diseases had other co-morbidities
and so you know anyone who can read
between the lines would have realized
okay
that's what he died from and ami he just
happened to have omicron this is like
the stories you heard in 2020 when a guy
would get shot in the head
but he was listed as a kovid death
because he happened to have kovitz while
some guy was shooting him
so
that one
debunked not you heard it from the
horse's mouth you heard it from the
mouth of the harris county public health
department
but we're all going to get omicron we're
all going to get it and so you're going
to hear about a lot more omicron deaths
because people are still going to die of
all the normal things that they die from
and a lot of people are going to have
omicron and just because you die with
omicron does not mean you die from
omicron there's a story just came out of
texas
that that the omicron variant
has been detected in nearly every harris
county wastewater treatment facility
as the viral load is rising in downtown
houston basically every water treatment
plant in
the entire county
has
amicron
dr kevon mojared he is the director of
walter reed's infectious diseases branch
he has just said quote with omicron
there's really no way to escape the
virus you are not going to be able to
avoid it so i think pretty soon either
the whole world will be vaccinated or
have been infected
or
both
i'm just speaking anecdotally but worth
remembering that the plural of anecdote
actually is data
i've got a ton of friends all over the
country who have kovid right now i guess
it would probably be the omicron that's
that's now the dominant strain in the
united states and it's apparently very
transmissible not very serious
not very life-threatening but but very
transmissible and
probably most of the people who have
gotten it are vaccinated
we all
we all know people who have the vaccine
many of whom have booster shots who
still get it
now it's unbelievable you're seeing the
left in real time
redefine vaccines bill gates the other
day said that the purpose of vaccines
not even just this vaccine but the
purpose of vaccines generally is not to
prevent you from getting viruses but to
mitigate
the symptoms which is obviously just
complete bs what are you talking about
we get the polio vaccine so that we only
get a milder form of polio is that is
that why we get it we get the meningitis
vaccine so that meningitis is not quite
as severe when we get it
uh no the vaccines are supposed to
prevent you from getting the virus and
that's what we were promised in the
early days of this vaccine and then the
vaccine failed and wasn't as effective
as people told us it was and so they
just redefined what vaccines are and
they said no no what are you talking
about you crazy anti-science conspiracy
theorist vaccines were never supposed to
prevent you from getting viruses no it's
just supposed to
possibly mitigate the symptoms
oh okay well that's interesting where'd
that how far do you have to move the
goal post to get to that definition it's
like you're in a different football
field now you move those goal posts so
far
regardless this is actually good news
i'm actually glad to hear
if we're going to have covid if we're
going to have these viruses if we're
going to have this very transmissible
variant i am pleased to hear that it's
just everywhere now
that it's in every water treatment
facility in this county and it's going
all over the country
i'm pleased to hear it
because it means you should go to
christmas
go to christmas dinner
tune out dr fauci
go to christmas dinner
see your family
see your friends
do you have the vaccine go to christmas
dinner do you not have the vaccine go to
christmas dinner
doesn't matter you're all going to get
it you're all going to get it and i know
now they're pretending that if you have
the vaccine you're probably not gonna
get it but you will
you will we all know it because we all
know people who have the vaccine who
just in the past couple of weeks have
gotten it okay so just go
the dye is cast all right just live your
lives
live your lives that's it there's
nothing there's nothing you can do
the only choice the choice is not get
coveted or don't get coveted the choice
now is
cower in fear in your closet for another
three years
or
go live your life
seems
seems like the latter is going to be
more enjoyable it's in the water folks
it's in the water treatment facilities
you're not escaping it you might even
get it while you're cowering in your
closet speaking of waters
this is going to be the best transition
i've ever done in the history of this
show speaking of waters
my friend jessie waters has gotten in
trouble recently
because jessie waters is a a
show tv show host at fox news jesse
waters was speaking at the turning point
usa conference a week or so ago
and
jesse
got in trouble because the left-wing
media said he threatened to kill
dr fauci he threatened he encouraged
people to go out there and shoot dr
fauci in the head
uh when i read that i i thought you know
i don't look
i'm not saying that jesse waters and i
are bosom buddies but i know the guy a
little bit i don't i don't think he's
the sort of fella to do that
that said let me
let me go find the speech and you'll
notice that all the left-wing networks
that are that are pushing this none of
them are showing you the actual speech
so i thought okay there's the dead
giveaway he didn't really say that
take a listen to what jesse waters
actually said
you gotta ambush a guy like fauci okay
this is how you do these ambushes like
o'keeffe
you got to be respectful
because they'll turn the tables on you
and you can't have a blow up in your
face so if you see fouchy out and about
and you know he's coming to town this is
how you approach okay
keep a little document in your pocket
all right
this is the grant
that funded the research it's in your
pocket not even rand paul has been able
to get in his face and point with the
grant in his face
so then
he's in trouble
now you going for the kill shot
the kill shot
with an ambush
deadly
because he doesn't see it coming
this is when you say
dr fauci
you funded risky research at a sloppy
chinese lab the same lab that sprung
this pandemic on the world
you know why people don't trust you
don't you
boom
he is dead
okay does anyone watching that clip
believe that jesse waters is encouraging
people to go out and shoot dr fauci in
the head
no he's obviously speaking rhetorically
he's obviously speaking metaphorically
right he's saying
are you saying here's here's the ambush
the ambush is not throwing a net on him
or tackling him the ambush is hey i've
got this document and then here's the
kill shot the kill shot is not a bullet
to the head the kill shot is
you funded this risky research at a
filthy chinese laboratory
that then had a virus escape and okay
fair enough
well the left is going bonkers with this
they think this is an opportunity to
take out a conservative tv host and so
not only is cnn talking about how awful
this is not only are the left-wing media
dr fauci himself is saying jesse waters
should be fired
now speaking of americans keeping their
jobs
good ranchers
is a wonderful wonderful
way to support american ranchers and get
great meat this christmas give your
friends and family the gift of meat do
it this is great good ranchers
you will be able to get a box of 100
american meat that is steakhouse quality
goodranchers.com they got a variety of
boxes to give to your friends or to try
for yourself giving a gift to numero uno
this season choose the ranchers classic
for the perfect combo of high quality
beef and tender chicken or go with the
cowboy
that way you will have the ultimate
steakhouse experience with black angus
rib eyes wagyu burgers and more get
twenty dollars off and free shipping on
your order with the code knowles knwes
at checkout you know
with good ranchers you are not going to
find
this kind of high quality beef for this
price anywhere the value per penny ratio
here is out of control and i you know
for some people you know having steak is
like a real splurge it certainly was
when i was a kid well good ranchers
makes it such that you can have beef and
steak a little more regularly really top
quality stuff so get your good rancher's
box or gift card today tis the season
for open hearts and full stomachs give
good ranchers with my code knowles
canadawlas for 20 bucks off and free
shipping goodranchers.com
knowles use code knowles at checkout to
take advantage of this special christmas
offer
go check out good ranchers today
dr fauci dr fauci
is
horrified by the suggestion made by
jesse waters that people should confront
him over his funding of the wuhan
research facility
and so dr fauci says jesse waters needs
to get fired
well john that's horrible i mean that
just is such a reflection of the
craziness that goes on in society the
only thing that i have ever done
throughout these two years
is to encourage people to practice good
public health practices to get
vaccinated to be careful in public
settings to wear a mask and for that you
have some guy out there saying that
people should be giving me a kill shot
to ambush me
i mean what kind of craziness is there
in society these days that's awful that
he said that and he's going to go very
likely unaccountable
i mean whatever network he's on is not
going to do anything for him i mean
that's crazy the guy should be firing on
the spot
should be fired on the spot there's only
one person in this situation who should
be fired on the spot who should have
been fired on the spot a very long time
ago that would be the guy who has run
the infectious diseases branch of
nih for seven presidents
the guy who screwed up aids who engaged
in extremely risky
illegal at one point research in into
gain of function research and then who
screwed up the entire response to the
pandemic
that would be dr anthony fauci
he should be fired he should be fired he
should very likely be prosecuted at
least for perjury don't forget he
perjured himself while he was testifying
before the senate he said that he didn't
fund gain of function research and he
did and we have all the evidence that he
did
and
he should be banished to saint helen
okay i know people are going to say
that's too far no
fired for sure
prosecuted for sure
banished to a far-flung island where he
can never exert his terrible political
influence again
probably at least i'm all for it that
might be a harder pitch to some people
but i'm all for it and uh as fauxchi
predicted fox news is sticking by jesse
waters i think that's great
i think it's really great that fox news
is sticking by one of their on-air
personalities when his comments were
taken completely out of context by
leftist
democrat operatives i think that's
really that's that's good to see
maybe a little surprising these days but
it's good i'm glad i'm glad that fox did
that
so good job good job fox that's great
glad that jesse waters is going to make
it
speaking of
killing
there is a possible hung jury
in the trial of kim potter i haven't
followed this all that closely i suspect
a lot of people have not followed this
trial all that closely kim potter is the
woman she's a cop who shot a young
career criminal he was young but he was
already a career criminal his name was
dante wright and he was she shot him
while he was resisting arrest wright had
a warrant out for his arrest related to
aggravated armed robbery
for failure to appear in court fleeing
police officers possessing a gun without
a permit he also had a restraining order
out forbidding contact with a woman so
he really
he did a lot despite not being all that
old
so she shot him during this altercation
the complicating factor here is that
potter admitted after she shot him that
she meant to use a taser she meant to
shoot him with a taser she actually shot
him with a gun and then he got in the
car with a so he gets shot he gets in
the car with his girlfriend in the car
and then just drives off and crashes the
car and injures his girlfriend but
apparently that doesn't bother him all
that much it certainly didn't
i i hope there's a hung jury or i hope
she gets acquitted i
if this is my this is my meta legal my
meta political analysis here of you know
we're all parsing the law and what
happens if she did this and she admitted
she wanted the taser in this and here's
my main takeaway
if you're a violent career criminal
resisting arrest
don't be surprised when a cop shoots you
don't
play stupid games win stupid prizes
that's this is really good advice and i
hope that everyone who is considering
becoming a career criminal and
considering resisting arrest listens to
my advice and takes it very much to
heart
if you do that
do not be surprised when a cop shoots
you
you you have been warned don't
don't think that you have not been
warned chris rock made a good point on
this number of years ago he said look if
if you're really concerned about getting
a beating at the hands of the police
here's some simple advice on how to
avoid that
have you ever been face to face with a
police officer and wondered
is he about to kick my ass well wonder
no more if you follow these easy tips
you'll be fine
first
obey the law
laws were made for a reason think of
them as hints you've heard people say
man i wouldn't do that [ __ ] if i was you
well here's some of that
carjacking armed robbery arson selling
drugs buying drugs stabbing shooting you
know you probably won't get your ass
kicked if you just use common sense
if you jump a subway turnstile you might
just get off with a warning from the
police
but if you jump a turnstile carrying a
loaded gun and smoking a joint
then maybe you need your ass kicked
we all know what happened to rodney king
but rodney wouldn't have got his ass
kicked if he had just followed this
simple tip
when you see flashing police lights in
your mirror stop immediately
everybody knows if the police have to
come and get you they're bringing an ass
kicking wicket
good advice then good advice now
so
it's sad sad when people die
but that's that's what's going to happen
now
you could ask this question
should the cop
have tased dante wright instead i'm not
so sure by the way tasers don't work
that well
they can be if you don't want to
carry lethal force and you don't want to
have a gun or maybe you're not really
trained in firearms so you don't want to
be carrying a gun all the time and maybe
it could be taken away from you okay
then you know taser is a good option
but
tasers sometimes don't work
you shoot a taser
you got to hit someone in a right in the
right spot you got to make sure it
catches on to them then it can work very
well but it might not work you only get
one shot so if that shot's
done then you're in then you're in a
quite a bit of trouble
but maybe i mean she intended to shoot
him with the taser
then the question becomes
should you be convicted of a crime and
sent to prison
over
over a mistake she didn't mean to shoot
him with the gun
and should you do that after you've
served a long time as a cop
when you
used more force than you intended to use
on a violent career criminal resisting
arrest
but but maybe not more force than you
could
could have been permitted to use and i
think not i hope she gets off maybe she
shouldn't be a cop anymore
maybe she should receive some kind of
professional punishment
maybe she should be assigned to desk
duty or kicked off the force maybe but
to send her to prison that's
insane to me that's insane to me and it
and it i think
has much more to do with our idolatry of
violent criminals and our embrace of
insane racial narratives
in america than it does with what this
woman actually did
of course
well we want to follow just authority
and it's good good advice to to do that
when you get pulled over by a cop you
know don't don't act out just kind of be
polite and go along with it you'll
probably be just fine uh you don't want
to follow unjust authority
there is a uh viral video
it's i guess it's a comedy video
not you're not you know it's not uh
exactly dangerfield but but it's oh
it's i guess it's supposed to be comedy
about how we
should just do whatever fauci tells us
to do
i've just had my third shot
a booster they call it
how many more are they gonna make us get
don't know don't care because i like you
probably understand there is a global
pandemic and people much much smarter
than you and me have decided this is the
best plan of action to avoid lots more
people dying or cluttering up hospital
hallways
you and i we're doing our part by
getting one more little prick
and not being one
and not being one so just do whatever
fauci says even though fauci has
contradicted himself at least half a
dozen times during this epidemic just
whatever he says at this moment
do that because these are people who are
much smarter than you and me listen
buddy
i'm not
disputing the fact that these people are
much smarter than you
but just because they're smarter than
you does not mean they're smarter than
me
and it doesn't mean that they're smarter
than the rest of us
i don't think that our ruling class
is smarter
than
a lot of americans i don't think that dr
fauci is smarter
he's certainly not wiser
than
the great many americans who oppose him
i don't think whatever little he knows
about some scientific field he doesn't
seem to know jack diddly about
philosophy
morality
political philosophy our system of
government
or much of anything else for that matter
and these these questions
really
should weigh into our decision on how
how we react to his edicts
i am now of the opinion
that any republican who does not
promise to prosecute anthony fauci
should not be taken seriously in 2024
this is not hyperbole this is not just
some emotional outburst because i don't
like fouchy or we're angry that fauci is
making us do certain things
i think it's pretty clear that he's
committed at least one crime
he perjured himself he perjured himself
before a committee of the united states
senate over a very important question
which is
his role
in
the pandemic his role in starting the
pandemic potentially by funding risky
research the same sort of research that
almost certainly created the virus that
escaped from the wuhan laboratory
again you have to say almost certainly
or almost definitely or because there's
we don't really know because there are
cover-ups going on in china there are
cover-ups going on at the world health
organization there are cover-ups going
on in the united states so we don't we
don't have a hundred percent certainty
but all the evidence we've got suggests
that the virus did not just come from
some wet market it came from the wuhan
laboratory the united they came from
research called gain of function
research that takes natural viruses and
beefs them up it makes them more
virulent and makes them more
transmissible that kind of research
despite fouchy lying in front of the
senate that research was funded by fauci
and the nih
and look at the results everyone knew
that this was dangerous research fauchi
admitted it was dangerous and he said
yeah whatever i think it's worth the
risk and now look where we are so he
should be prosecuted at the very least
for
for perjury
we have to look at the timeline on when
this funding went through because the
funding was illegal for for at least
some period of time
that would be another potential crime
and as a political matter this man has
too much power and he is he is almost
single-handedly upending our system of
government
and screwing up our way of life and
taking away our rights and he really
when i say he needs to be banished to
say helena i'm
only being
three percent humorous
okay we in
athenian democracy
back in ancient athens you know this
model of democracy
banishment was a real
punishment
when you had a once popular leader
powerful leader who the people didn't
like anymore they would banish him for
10 years to an island and frankly it's
not not the worst idea when napoleon was
done ravaging europe what did they do
they banished him to an island
not a bad idea lots of similarities
between
anthony fauci and napoleon
now yes it's true whichever republican
it is might squish out in the end you
remember we heard lock her up lock her
up you know well if i'm elected you'd be
in jail that sort of thing and then what
happens no no one really goes after
hillary fine that's true but i'd at
least like to get these candidates on
the record it's a matter of justice and
it's a matter of existential political
necessity
there's one potential 2024 candidate
who has already asked the doj to launch
a criminal investigation into anthony
fauci that man would be my co-host on
the verdict podcast senator ted cruz so
he i guess he's already on the record he
hasn't he hasn't come out and said he's
running for president in 2024
privately you know to me or anyone else
or publicly
but he has as a u.s senator already
asked for this criminal investigation
unfortunately
the executive
branch is the branch that prosecutes so
merrick garland joe biden's attorney
general is just not going to do it but a
republican attorney general could
and
ted cruz might be running for president
in 2024 there is a young interviewer
this kid is a teenager from the truth
gazette and he's gotten some pretty big
names
to to interview so one of them is ted
cruz and the kid asked him hey are you
running for president 2024 and i think
basically for the first time cruz said
very possibly
we have another election coming up in
2024 so aside from the terms what are
your thoughts on the field of potential
candidates going into 2024 and would you
ever consider another run for president
absolutely uh
in a heartbeat you know i ran in 2016.
uh it was the most fun i've ever had in
my life
we had a very crowded field we had 17
candidates in the race very strong field
and and i ended up placing second and
you know there's a reason historically
that the runner-up is almost always the
next nominee and and that's been true
going back to
nixon or reagan or or mccain or romney
that that has played out repeatedly
uh you come in with just just enormous
base of support you know in 2016
we raised over 92 million dollars uh
that was the most money any republicans
ever raised in the history of
presidential primaries
so this this is a good point
and it's one that
had not occurred to me for for a while
but the the runner-up does tend to be
the next nominee so this this puts cruz
in a pretty good position
for 2024. now the the complicating
factor is trump because trump only got
one term and he is
indicated his interest in running again
although it's not clear if he really
wants to run again or if he just wants
to be a king maker
or if they would even let him win
if the establishment the ruling class
would let him win
if he did run
but it seems to me right now the big
contenders are trump
trump is
the the big guy in the field he's
polling
way higher than anybody else
ron desantis he's he's sort of the hot
republican right now there's always a
hot republican
uh he
one hopes he didn't peak too soon
he did kind of he's been he's been
peaking for a while i mean he's really
maintained a lot of support
he's done a great job on covid
and cruz who you know what desantis is
doing a great job as a governor cruz is
doing a great job as a senator
and then trump
is right
trump is doing a great job as a former
president and potential future president
so that that kind of covers it those are
the three lanes you know the president
lane the governor lane and the
in the senate lane
um
it's hard to see another candidate
really breaking through that
right now so people are gonna have to
pick their teams although i the thing is
if trump runs it's very possible he
would clear the field
but he may not run and trump i think
does have a slight political
uh
complication right now
which we'll get to in just one second
first though
this week we released an exclusive
face-to-face interview between candace
and trump
welcome to a most special episode of
candace
each time that i've interviewed
president trump they have never told me
that i am not allowed to ask him
anything and today i want to talk about
some topics that are on i think
everybody's mind
[Music]
where do you stand on these vaccine
mayonnaise what's going on there you
talk about mass you talk about mandates
julian assange edward snowden i mean you
could have had a chance to pardon these
individuals you have two sides of it
anything that looking back you think i
got that one wrong did you get covered
uh no did you have the vaccine no
no kitty i'm very impressed with you
alec baldwin is he gonna get arrested i
think he's crazy this is the toughest
question i could possibly ask you tell
me one good thing joe biden has done in
office she's done this before right he
is completely unscripted it's one of the
things that fascinates me about him what
you see is exactly what you get
all right mr president
and it's pretty great the interview is
streaming exclusively to members at
dailywire.com so head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe to join today
and start watching if you want to show
your support for truth seekers like
candace head on over to
yesweekcandice.com pick up some terrific
candace merchandise ben also has a new
show it's called the search you really
got to check it out his uh good friend
jordan peterson is the first guest to
join him
it's great you can just be a fly on the
wall
on their conversation
when they're in a coffee shop head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe we'll be
right back with the mailbag
before we get to the mailbag just this
one just to wrap up this last point
trump has put himself in a tough
position
because he is defending the vaccines
as
one of the greatest achievements of his
or any administration in history
but a lot of his base doesn't really
like the vaccines or they think the
vaccines are being used as a political
tool so trump is saying i don't support
mandates but the vaccines are really
really great and we did a great job on
it that it's a tough issue for him i
don't
i don't think it was exactly a mistake
for you know i think he was just kind of
backed into this corner on covid but it
is a complicating fact it's probably the
weakest
area right now for him politically
looking into 2024 so he's gonna
that might give an opening to someone
like a desantis or someone like a cruise
or someone else who's running
but he's going to have to have an answer
to that
before before 2024 rolls around all
right let's get to the mailbag from
sarah michael this is not a very serious
question for your illustrious mailbag
however this is a rather heated debate
in the religious community
what do you think about telling your
kids about santa claus
on the one hand it's a joyful practice
with a moral or original story
on the other hand
it's lying to your kids about a fat man
sneaking into their home and giving them
gifts rather than their family what will
you be telling your kid about santa
thanks yeah i like santa i'm pro santa
so it's based in reality right there is
such a man as saint nicholas saint
nicholas actually did
give
little monies and coins and and things
like that
to kids and to poor people
uh and he was he's a great saint of the
church a bishop of barry
so
it was based in reality and i like it
it's kind of fun i like the idea of the
tooth fairy like the easter bunny it's
good it's fun for kids to have these
imaginative things the only fear would
be that
the kids when they find out that santa
claus is made up that they would think
that jesus is made up too
or some or saint nicholas for that
matter you know
uh
real people
with a real
direct relation to the faith
that they would begin to doubt their
faith generally but i i just don't i'm
not too worried about that i think if
you're well catechized and you have a
good
good foundation that you'll be just fine
and it's nice for kids to have fun
silly pretend things to enjoy from liam
dier connoisseur of cafe i've written
into the mailbag before with political
philosophical questions but now i seek
your famed relationship advice i met a
girl on a dating app she's from a
foreign country and we both have
conflicting work schedules so it's been
hard to communicate with each other
however from how well i've been able to
get to know her well enough at least to
be sure i'm not being catfished i really
like her we're both unwilling to take
the fauchiachi and because of brandon's
travel restrictions on the unclean it
would be difficult for us to meet in
person
my heart tells me to go get the girl
well my brain says it's impossible and
that even if it were possible it
wouldn't be worth the difficulty being
that i don't even know her that well
what is your advice
my advice is that you don't know the
girl
really at all you you've exchanged
messages
she's
and apparently not even all that
frequently or regularly because your
schedules are completely opposite and
you just met on a on a dating app and
she's on the other side of the world
and
often people
mistake
infatuation
with
love
infatuation
is
similar it produces similar feelings
but it's not grounded in reality
it may well be the case because you
as you say you don't know this girl very
well
that you are in love with a fictional
image that you have made of this girl
really you're just in love with your own
desires that you are projecting onto
this girl
rather than the girl herself
and this can be intoxicating because
because she's the woman of your dreams
because she literally is the woman of
your dream she is a figment of your
imagination
the only caveat it may well be
that she's a great girl
it may well be that she
really is the love of your life i don't
know i guess keep talking to her i guess
do facetime or whatever you know spend
time in whatever way that you can and
try to see if you develop a real
relationship
stranger things have happened
but if you're having this kind of
intensity of feeling after just a
handful of messages on a dating app
irregularly you know when maybe you're
not even sending them or receiving them
at the same time that's much more likely
to be infatuation than it is to be love
from andrew hey michael you mentioned
the other day how the fourth of july is
a secular holiday
george washington conveyed in his
inauguration speech that all
this winning this country was from god
so i was thinking that as a religious
person if we embrace the fourth of july
the celebration of our founding to be
something from god couldn't that mean
that the fourth of july for religious
people and a day
not sure that grammar is a little off
here in a day to celebrate getting this
country from god and for the seculars
not curious your thoughts on this thanks
love your show and all that you do uh
yes well all of our holidays really
should reflect gratitude toward god and
the founding fathers understood this
and we have forgotten it because we've
created this silly notion that we're a
completely secular country and we have a
separation of church and state and
that's just bogus and it's
anti-historical and it's incoherent
because god does exist and so given that
god exists that's what all of our
forefathers the great statesmen who
built our country going back not just to
the founding era but to the mayflower
they all knew that
and we've somehow forgotten it largely
but if it is the case as it is that god
exists then setting up your country in
opposition to god is probably not a
smart idea
uh that said
uh there are certain holidays are a
little a little less religious than
others
right uh
arbor day
is not particular it's religious in the
sense that god makes trees but it you
know it's not quite quite so religious
uh veterans day
not quite not quite so but it's still
religious right when we're you're going
out there you're defending your
country or we're giving gratitude to the
people who've gone out and defended our
country
why why would they even do that because
there is this transcendent moral order
and there's right and wrong and so yeah
and that relates to god too
um i would take your
your letter as a
really
le good lesson a good piece of advice
which is that recognize that every
everything everything in your life
everything that you do
and everything that we do as a nation
has some connection to god
because god is the creator and sustainer
of the universe
and he made you and
so
that might affect the way that you live
your life and it should affect the way
that you live your life and it should
affect the way that
we run our nation from nick
hey michael me again here we go nick
nick nick it's been a while
i don't even know who i don't even know
how many nicks there are at this point i
sort of get i get this feeling that
multiple people are writing in his neck
nick it's me whatever okay hi michael me
again i'm dating a jew
okay
i've put up walls around my heart
recently so i don't really identify as
dating but she's definitely picking up
what i'm putting down anyway i throw an
awesome christmas party every year and
she is super jewish so much so her
family has banned her from coming even
so she's planning on sneaking over and
defying her family this could have huge
repercussions for her if she's caught
now i've never been that kind of home
wrecker so what should i do
should i tell her to honor her family's
demand or tell her to start pregaming at
11 am
sincerely
your brother from another mother
how old is this girl nick
if she's got a sneak out of her parents
you know don't you shouldn't be dating
high school high school students uh
hopefully she's a little older and just
happens to be living with her family
this is actually a good question
you're
christian
potential i don't know i'm not sure what
nick's religious views are but you're
celebrating christmas so let's say
you're christian the girl's jewish and
you want to get together
that's good
i'm not saying that you guys are going
to get married yet doesn't sound like
you're ready exactly to settle down but
you will need to resolve this issue and
i think it's great i think that if you
convert her to christianity really the
holy spirit will convert it to
christianity but you might play some
role in it if you do that then that
would be a good thing
and
you could have a nice family and you but
you but
the family really does need to have
at least similar religious views and
really should be the same religion
faith is a very powerful thing even if
you don't believe it to be a powerful
thing right now even if you're one of
the people who thinks oh come on i'm
agnostic i'm not an atheist i'm sorry
i'm spiritual but not religious oh i
don't care about all these distinctions
between religions and denominations and
you know it's like whatever man come on
who cares
you do it does matter
because faith shapes
everything about our lives it shapes the
way we see the world whether we will
admit it or not
it shapes the way we view
society shapes the way we view child
rearing
shapes the way we view marriage
i would recommend
before you get married
to this girl
that you you've just met so might be a
while i would recommend that you
sort out at least the basic aspects of
this question
but i wouldn't feel bad about uh
you know
bringing this girl over away from the
religion of her parents that's that's
the way it happens oh christ says that
he says i have come to divide
you know divide families right i've i
have come not to bring peace but a sword
you know and so that that happens and uh
you you can't i don't think that uh
it's very effective for a parent to just
say if you leave my religion
i'm gonna be really angry with you i
don't i don't think that's necessarily
the most effective uh
way to keep someone in a faith
from ben dear michael knowles which
version of the bible do you prefer i've
heard good things about the new american
bible and bad things about the king
james version and was wondering which
version provides the best reading of the
bible the king the king james version is
one of the most beautiful works of of
english ever composed
uh so i don't know where you heard that
king james version is great
i i tend to favor the revised standard
version
catholic edition so you got to remember
there's
the protestant bible took out a bunch of
books so you won't get as many books in
the protestant bible but uh
so i'd recommend a catholic version the
dewey reims i would really recommend is
great
um but in terms of just going to spot
check different verses and things i
usually use the rsvce
from john
since we will not be hearing from you
until 2022 what are a few of your
resolutions for the new year thanks
one of them is
to engage in
just a very small amount of exercise
regularly
i don't i don't want to go become arnold
schwarzenegger
i don't want to ever go on a run
that does not interest me in the least
i don't want to put on latex
you know whatever like suits to go on
long bike rides or on a run or so that's
uh-uh ain't me
ain't me dog but i do have this
wonderful echelon
exercise bike this stationary bike in my
home i want to do that mostly because
i uh you know i'd like to prolong my
life
a little bit you know be around see my
grandkids that kind of thing not saying
i gotta live forever but i'd like to i
would wouldn't want to live prematurely
necessarily and so uh so i think that
would be a good thing to do very much
i'm keeping very modest goals
for my resolutions so that i
am more likely to keep them from mike
dear michael would love to hear your
thoughts on deciphering between
intelligence and being well read or
educated i'd say that these things can
often go hand in hand but also believe
that just because you can recite a
passage from shakespeare it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're intelligent
how do you define intelligence and who
is the most intelligent person that
you've come into contact with love the
show sincerely how about dem apples
well it's funny because the way you're
saying it right now is you're saying
that just because you're extremely well
read and knowledgeable doesn't mean
you're intelligent
so as if it's better to have a high iq
than to know things but i kind of think
it's the opposite
you asked the most intelligent person i
ever met
i don't know they're a handful of people
my college roommate is certainly up
there
uh there are a lot of people jeremy
bourne oh my gosh jeremy boring's iq is
probably through the rule i mean a lot
of people here at the daily wire i'm
saying you know all my colleagues are
you know have have high iqs but the best
red person i ever met probably doesn't
have as high in iq
and i'm not going to say his name on air
because i don't want to destroy his
career but
he's in academia he's in very
prestigious positions in academia and
he's just read everything so maybe his
iq is a little bit lower than some other
people i've met
but
he he just knows so much more and so i
just think yeah even if you didn't place
in the top percentile on an iq test who
cares don't don't let that kind of silly
determinism discourage you just read a
bunch of books and think about them and
you know cultivate your spirit and your
knowledge and and your the life of the
mind and you can you can be a lot wiser
than people who have a much higher iq
all right that's the show
merry christmas everybody wonderful
and happy new year i guess i won't see
you until the new year a wonderful year
thank you so much you've made my year
such a delight
it's a great great pleasure and honor to
be with you all the time see you in
2022.
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
hints his health might stop him from
running for president again the facts
are out on omicron they cut against
panic and a democratic congresswoman is
mugged by reality that's today on the
ben shapiro show give it a listen